papa
[Musique]
conséquence d'une nouvelle philosophie
de l'évasion d'un besoin de flânerie en
société à l'échelle des grands ensembles
et des plombs géante et parce que
parfaitement adaptée aux goûts des
jeunes les drugstores surgissent d'un
peu partout dans tous les quartiers dont
ils deviennent vite le centre
d'attraction
[Musique]
lieu de passage de toute une population
quelle que soit l'heure quel que soit le
sexe l'âge ou le milieu social cela
tient à la fois de la brasserie ellery
marchands du bazar synthèse moderne de
tous ces lieux de rencontres qui ont eu
lieu en europe noire
c'est là qu'on assiste le plus grand
brassage de générations de luca ici les
barrières sociales fondent dans
l'alignement
[Musique]
le phénomène en est encore à ses
balbutiements et pourtant le vis déjà
une faune qui secoue les vieilles
traditions individualiste du français
qu'est ce que vous pensez des sons
appellerait les nordistes orient bon on
se prend qui est un type de roxton
plusieurs hymnes rock story ça dépend
simplement de l'heure avec un eagle au
calme et la décontraction
c'était beaucoup plus reposant que les
petits cafés des tarifs d'abord tout est
bon
[Musique]
me suis habitué le matin quelques fois
pour en compter de jeudi que j'habite le
quartier alors on retrouve l'ambiance
est agréable mais il n'ya qu'une heure
9h10 - à 9 heures
[Applaudissements]
il ya tout à tour on trouve de tout ce
qu'on veut un beau coup on peut manger
un peu discuté en page ce sont les
journaux surtout l'ambiance américaine
ici je peux pas influencer
oui simple énormément notre on trouve
tout ce qu'on veut et si ça vous dit
oui ça me dépasse un petit peu oui oui
je pense que les gens qui gagnent fois
tout à fait différent suivant le moment
de la journée
[Musique]
nous avons de petits habitués de gentils
midinettes qui viennent déjeuner le midi
le midi ils ont des gens qui sont
pressés avec bien manger
bien monté
c'est en marchant fois qu'ils auront
bien pour ça d'ailleurs
je première fois ici pour une raison
bien simple il est actuellement 16h15 et
je pense que dans le quartier c'est à
peu près le seul endroit où l'on puisse
encore des jeux nes on peut dire des
jeunes et à ceux versés pour des jeunes
on peut prendre un petit truc ça n'a pas
d'importance ont fait part des génies
complet comme dans un restaurant
[Musique]
après midi nous avons envoyé rituel que
nous considérons quand même avec
sympathie malgré tout ensuite nous avons
malgré tout bascule ou comme bien du fil
à retordre quelquefois un bon ils sont
turbulents
ils envahissent à l'année seront pas
trop visible mais vers quelle heure en
général soit cinq heures le soir entre
le center on vient à partir de 9 heures
mais on vient surtout ici pour
rencontrer des amis comme on aime
beaucoup cet endroit d'un endroit très
jeune un jeu je m'entends des jeunes
gens de 17 ans 18 ans mais pour prendre
un verre c'est surtout un certain
snobisme ou le soir un peu paris alors
c'est fou comme julien la province
[Musique]